the first hotspot system in Italy is
operational already in the island of
Lampedusa the first relocation plane of
Eritrea is from Italy to Sweden this
means that they have been registered
fingerprinted identified and scream for
a location in sajid immobilize a
gas-fueled large on face obviously we
have to get fresh funds available we
need to mobilize further staff through
Frontex as I said and we have to have
immediate action to establish a
dedicated return office within frantic
terrorism still casts a dark shadow over
the European Union the series of attacks
perpetrated or attempted on European
soil in the year 2015 are a stark
reminder of the existing terrorist
threat security on the menu prosper
ferrovia safety on the railways we
should avoid overreacting to the events
that have occurred and we should think
more about how to boost railway security
while at the same time respecting the
fundamental principles for public
transport accessibility and ease of use
just you have you demand pleased to
announce that it has been possible to
adopt a general approach on the
regulation on data protection imagine
you are a witness a suspect or a victim
of crime how can you ensure that the
details you provide to the police are
duly protected I will step up
discussions is the u.s. my goal is clear
we need a safer safe harbor
the pepper metra que su le fool we
should try to ensure that the internet
is not used to express messages of hate
which can actually incite people to
violence what is partly happening and
increasingly happening online on
Facebook is not only a metaphor dialogue
with Facebook most of it is under
criminal law